russell wilson who
if he's not the best quarterback in the
nfl
right now
i mean he is tell me who is i mean look
82.5 through two games
nine touchdowns any 11 incompletions now
i mean and maybe you just need to we
need to kind of like
you know be real
specific when we talk about best
quarterback in nfl if i'm starting a
team am i starting with russell wilson i
certainly would be more than happy
to do so but you can make an argument
for patrick mahomes of course you can
still make an argument for aaron rodgers
is he the does he have the best body of
work of any quarterback play right now
no of course that's tom brady but man
like
he's the guy period i don't think it's a
question right now he's the guy right
now
you know he got the juice right now
russell wilson is the best quarterback
in the nfl with apologies to patrick
mahomes
a couple of things last night that i'm
just watching russell wilson and i said
okay you just got to give it up
one yeah now this is just just context
he goes at the defensive player of the
year last year stephon gilmore goes at
him match up that dk metcalf fearlessly
stefan gilmore one on one 54 yards
that throw was flawless that was a
flawless throw with somebody it was
great
great coverage and i've seen gilmore do
this many times where gilmore kind of
puts the arm out so he anticipated he
knew what was coming he puts the arm out
metcalf you know big guy he's not as big
as i am but you know
he got a little got a little uh muscle
to him he was able to bring it in with
his strength but you can't have a better
throw than that and just the recognition
and and just the the placement of the
ball that was one but the one to more on
the other side
yeah uh once again uh great great
coverage by the twin jason mccourty on
more
and more had a nice job nice presence of
mind to catch the ball one foot in
bounds and then the other foot hits the
pylon that makes it good
but
he's just doing stuff that
you could talk about coverage and hey we
got to be aware of this you could be
aware of everything but when you're
playing at that level mike
can't do anything about it can't stop it
yeah
i mean look he would have to
he'd have to suffer some kind of
collapse so the seahawks would have to
just
struggle down the stretch with it which
they're not going to do with him for him
not to be mvp at this point i mean we'll
talk about mvp narratives in a second
but the narrative is already in his
favor like everybody by now is aware
that he has never
gotten an mvp vote in his illustrious
career
this could be a lifetime achievement
award for him this year
in addition to the fact that he's on his
way to having another brilliant campaign
he's going to end up being an mvp i have
a hard time seeing somebody stealing it
from him because he's already got one
national showcase game against the best
secondary in the league last year what
was it they gave up four touchdown
passes to receivers last year they had
he had four touchdowns past the
receivers last night you know what i
mean i mean he made stefan gilmore look
like a like a like a jag out there you
know what i mean so i think it's going
to take a lot for somebody to wrestle
mvp from him but beyond mvp
that mythical crown of best guy doing it
right now it's like i watched patrick my
home just today and no lead is safe with
patrick mahomes and you hate to overlook
aaron rodgers because he's still so
breathtaking but man oh man russell
wilson like he's he's flawless right now
you might have used that word earlier
he's flawless his only blemish on his
you know record so far through two games
is a is an interception that went
through greg olsen's hands it wasn't his
fault that wasn't even his fault was it
his fault he's got 11 completions and
nine touchdowns man you cannot okay
let's go to our favorite subject madden
you could not have these numbers in
matin you would not have those numbers
that's 82 and a half percent i mean
that's that's ridiculous
all right now i'm gonna i'm gonna take a
step further i think seattle is the best
team of football
i i think i think they are
and
because it's really not really a stretch
it's not much of a stretch to say that
because if we think he's the number one
quarterback
and you look at what they've done in the
first couple weeks of the season atlanta
not a great defense patriots are pretty
good defense and if you don't like their
players you know at least you like the
brains that are that are designing the
defense and he just said he was able to
slice to them they had no answers for
him i think it's the number one offense
in the league
and i think uh at the end of the season
we're going to be talking about seattle
uh when we go to the super bowl you down
going for a super bowl i mean you down
for it when we go
we're going to be talking about the
seattle seahawks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports